breaking news out of Washington an
explosive meeting in Washington as Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer reportedly walk
out of a meeting with President Trump
the topic at hand Syria according to top
Democrats Trump called for Pelosi a
third-rate politician here to break it
all down Kevin cork Kevin earlier today
I said well it will get back to you if
there anything big happens at the White
House and here you are and there you
have it right well done that's a
Colorado connection get it done for you
there on the five let me just say this
White House says the president was
measured decisive and factual they
called the walk off by Nancy Pelosi
baffling but not surprising as for
Pelosi herself well her colleagues say
the president was downright insulting he
was having a meltdown
here's what Chuck Schumer said about it
not long ago he was insulting
particularly to the speaker she kept her
cool completely but he called her a
third-rate politician he said that the
there are communists involved and you
guys might like that I mean this was not
a dialogue it was sort of a diatribe a
nasty diatribe not focused on the facts
fair and balanced that's the Democrat
side of things on the GOP side they say
the speaker didn't really have an
intention of listening or contributing
to this issue she just wanted some well
have her way here's mr. McCarthy see a
pattern of behavior with Speaker Nancy
Pelosi
she storms out of another meeting trying
to make it unproductive the other
Democrats stayed and actually had a very
productive meeting and you probably know
this Dana there was actually another
meeting scheduled for tomorrow about
Syria that meeting has been cancelled we
are told and given what happened today
probably not the worst idea
Dana all right thanks Kevin Cork at the
White House you had a boy a third-rate
politician is a compliment yeah if
somebody called me a third-rate Papapa
it's better than being a first-rate
politician a first-rate politician
you're just a phony jackass but like
Trump is a 12th rate politician he
doesn't even register so it's actually a
compliment look this is obviously the
worst thing that has ever happened since
yesterday when the worst thing that ever
happened happened and then before that
the fact is every day with these people
it's the worst thing their hair is on
fire all the time you can see it from
space there smokey heads are flaming I
don't care about anymore you can
disagree with him about this a lot of
people do you know but the fact is he's
the suit Trump is he's America's cab
driver he believes that like you asked
him if you go your turn you know you
driving a cab and so there's on the
couch there we go
this Middle East business it's a bunch
of crap what are we doing there we're
there for twenty forty years no one gets
anything done it's terrible that's now
our president what's wrong with that
scary no it's actually you would fire a
human being because you want you want
somebody as your leader someone who
protects the flock someone who's wise
and someone wants American troops out of
harm's way
well in fact he's creating more risk why
do you think blazing normally on this
show we have sort of debate about things
that are Republican Democrat
conservative liberal libertarian
whatever but Greg this is like a hundred
and twenty nine Republicans today voting
with Democrats and reading all of the
House Republican leadership to say the
president is wrong
putting us Americans right here at home
at risk
Isis people being released to the world
without any country they have his best
interests in mind in the criticism in
the push back for me I think it's like
one of those things in the swamp
there's bipartisan consensus to stay in
Syria and then outside in the rest of
the country there's consensus to get the
hell out of Syria that's the disconnect
and the president's looking at both
parties we've made a mess of the Middle
East you've had the Arab Spring you've
had genocide you've had Wars you've had
everything going on a migration crisis
weapons of mass destruction and he's
going to say you know what enough let's
let the Turks fight the Kurds fight the
Syrians fight the array except for now
he's trying to figure out the diplomacy
piece which I think that you could agree
let's get out but maybe just try to
figure out a way to do it there's a
little bit less bloodshed is burry know
people are dying in Syria and Turkey and
everywhere including ours in New York
City by the way and my tax dollars are
paying the salary for those people who
are sitting there and storming out of
meetings and calling themselves
insulting in front of the cameras like
it's two little kids or three kids no he
didn't know he did it mom I don't care I
want them to figure it out because these
are high stakes in my opinion and as a
taxpayer these are lives so I'm so sick
of this civil war happening and the
insulting from the co-equal branch of
government we pay them and we put our
faith in them to hold these offices to
come to a consensus this is getting out
of control in my opinion well how do you
argue with the cab driver to say no you
know what you're missing a point or if
you're deliberately missing the point
all right so here's here's here's the
debate that's going on that we saw today
you have a group of people that are that
see the potential to hurt Trump in this
thing and so they're building it up
right this is this another thing
remember last week it was impeachment
now it's this they'll find something
else so I view a lot of this with this
this fight with suspicion it's in and
there is actually a legitimate point
that Trump is making and has been making
for almost 20 years but what I'm saying
to you is the the Republicans have
largely stayed with President Trump in
opposition to the impeachment but we see
something different here Greg and I
think it suggests Oracle comparison they
don't have to go back too far to win
President Obama decided not to enforce
the redline and I don't know what the
number was but I bet it was at least 130
Democrats who said President Obama that
is a terrible idea
you had three cabinet
Clinton Podesta and gates all right
books saying and carry-all saying that
was not a good decision that was a
terrible decision because it led to Isis
so it's not like this is unprecedented
right but I think the difference here
dana is the president apparently is
telling reporters those kurds who were
our allies and who died in our fight
there are no angels oh there's a lot of
saying a complicated issue everybody
stand by people what happened to the
south vietnamese you remember what
happened there my point is is that he
doesn't want Americans to die he if
other people want to fight and kill each
other which they've been doing want them
to he just sent a letter to Iran saying
don't be a fool but he's going to use
sanctions he's not already died they
already had the atrocities I think
President Trump could have had this all
all the result that he looks for now he
could have had before last week
Dana's point is well-taken everything
always could be done better right and
Trump is known for just going out and
making he shoots first and then names
later whatever you want to use the
metaphor the point is his simple his
simple logic and I don't mean simple as
stupid I mean that it's plain as day our
men aren't gonna get killed that's
exactly what he said and you could get
mad at him and disagree with them but he
will take he will accept the death of
the Kurds before he accepts the death of
American troops but he had the power to
what if you had but if you had the I
guess the question is you had the power
to prevent it and also I do think that
when they said when these Republicans
are saying we're afraid of what could
happen because if something happens in a
year or so well it's a way back way